[Music]
if you look at any of the kind of
counter cultural theorist that came out
of the 60s at Berkeley the the Neil
postman's the Theodore rose action are
they I had they really kind of
fundamentally even to the talking heads
like they kind of fundamentally they
meant something to me when I was
studying I was studying French
literature at Vanderbilt at Renaissance
literature which which really was the
period of literature that emerged after
the invention of the printing press and
at first it was pornography and comedy
and then it went into more secular
literature you know stories dramas etc
but but it was always kind of the first
to colonize his pornography and comedy
and and and then I started getting
really into these kind of counter
cultural theorist that we're looking at
the time at mass communications like
television and radio as these you know
everything from Big Brother to numbing
us to selling desire in America to
creating this you know kind of religion
of capitalism Twitchell wrote this
amazing book called ad cult where he he
equated modern advertising capitalism to
a religion and it had its iconography
and it had its Dogma and it's had it if
you do this then this will happen and if
you use the American Express card then
you two will have three percent body fat
walking down the beach with this
beautiful person on your arm and so
those were all these I think precursors
to what we're experiencing now because I
think we were we were really trained a
set of values in capitalism that meant
that money ruled all and people we're
talking about a troll president on
Twitter now but you know at the end of
the day a majority of people think that
a person that has a billion dollars is
smarter than everyone else and so at a
fundamental level if that's our religion
then this guy won he's he's a winner
he's you know got his billions of
dollars and his airplanes and his you
know Twitter account and he can speak
directly to to the masses you never see
what's I think is best thing you never
heard Donald Trump facebook
this right because that's not a raw feed
anymore that's controlled by algorithms
so he saw that Donald Trump tweets this
because it's still a raw fire hose and
so it's still a direct connection and so
we're constantly seeing these arbitrage
a--'s of these new characters that
emerge I mean I represented 6,500 kids
that had no fame whatsoever in the world
for years ago and then suddenly vine
came along and six seconds led to fame
an Instagram came along and you know
acacia Brinley took the perfect selfie
and at 17 had a million followers on
Instagram and so our value system
changed overnight right all the things
that we held valuable now we suddenly
saw and maybe it was always that way but
now we just had camera phones recording
it right so of like when people make the
comment about police brutality like well
it's always been there it's just now
we're recording it now we're seeing it
and so I think that we're going through
this really interesting phase especially
after this election where we now have a
majority of people connected in these
systems and we can now see a lot of
different aspects of the world that we
might not have been privy to because of
this top-down media right the idea that
you know the media was astonished that
60 million people in America voted a
different way is kind of a joke like you
weren't listening you were in such an
echo chamber you weren't and so they're
a victim of algorithmic their victim of
social segregation of algorithmic
segregation and so I think that we're
now starting to see everything for what
it is I think that we're actually
starting to to reabsorb our society and
we're starting to see it and now we have
these individual decisions to make at a
very granular level that I don't think
we ever thought of before and I don't
think that we saw our ramifications so
vividly portrayed in real quantitative
analysis and we're all getting data on
ourselves now that we didn't have before
we never maybe we melt off in class and
said something to another person
and you know somebody's at all you're a
jerk where but we didn't have
large-scale lynchings like we have now
in social media when you put something
out there I mean think about the
polarization that happened in this last
election where people are like i'm
unfriending you I'm you know blocking
you I'm d for you know it's like that
just created the bigger bigger schism in
our society except we're seeing it now
and I think that's the fascinating thing
that's happening is and that's why I
keep going back to this idea of
evolution evolution is not necessarily
progress it's one of the biggest themes
of the book that I hope that people
understand because they're very nuanced
ideas but just because something is
evolving and changing does it mean that
it's moving forward in a progressive
manner it doesn't mean that it's getting
better necessarily right we have you
know evolutionary moments throughout
living history where things going to
went this way and it didn't work out so
well and they've died off and they and
so you know hopefully a lot of these
directions where we're kind of seeing
hate for what it is right in immunology
there's a great example of this if you
look at the HIV virus you know we've now
been grappling with this what for over
30 years now and scientists have gotten
really good at containing it right you
can take a combination of you know drug
cocktail of heart treatment and you can
and you can go in and you can basically
eliminate the virus from the bloodstream
but the virus is tricky and that it
hides itself in dendritic cells and then
you know very deep kind of in stem cell
layer of our bodies and it can hide out
for 7 10 15 years and so the second you
stop suppressing you know HIV it pops
back up it mutates it becomes more
virulent etc and so there are two big
theories right now in modern kind of
treatment for that one is ferreting it
out trying to cause the body to trigger
to release you know the kind of store at
HIV by kind of shocking it and ferreting
it out I look at that a lot like what's
going on with hate that's varied inside
of these people we suddenly had a cat
list that's ferreting out these hate
emotions in our society and then the
other thing and the other way to really
cure it if you look at the Berlin
patient for instance or the delta i
believe it's Delta 32 variant was there
six percent of living Northern Europeans
that have an immunity to HIV or to the
most popular strain of HIV and so what
we're doing is in science we're now
taking stem cells from those people and
trying to rewrite a person that's
infected with HIV is body so that they
can recognize the antigen of HIV and so
that they can be use their own immune
system to either protect against it or
to get rid of it right to either
inoculate yourself against HIV and
change the actual T cells floating
around in your bloodstream or to
actually teach it how to recognize that
as a virus as a foreign antigen and to
then rid itself by using the own bodies
machinery so you're really re teaching
your body that this is bad I look at our
culture right now as the exact same
analogy because we have to teach
ourselves at a cellular level that this
is bad right I start the book off with
the Confederate flag for instance it
took 150 years and a mass shooting in
South Carolina for us and a guy you know
draped in the Confederate flag saying
want to create a race riot for us to
suddenly realize that maybe that flag is
racist maybe it's a symbol of hate maybe
it's a symbol that we need to get rid of
in our culture and so it then takes us
as individuals to learn that and to
change ourselves and do not propagate
that or to learn how to squash it out at
a local level and so I think the exact
same thing that we're learning now with
immunotherapy for HIV for cancer for all
those things about teaching our body
that this is bad I think we're now
learning that in our society of maybe
the hile Trump is a pretty terrible
thing that we should squash out pretty
quickly in our society and not let it
happen but had he not been there that
would stay underground
and would it fester would it get worse I
think there's a good moment that we're
seeing this for what it is so that we
can act upon it in a very organic
natural way and hopefully get rid of
this in our society as fast as possible
without letting it rise up and fester
and the notion that our media or us were
surprised that 60 million people around
us thought differently is a big warning
sign who would be surprised that 60
million people thought differently if
you are aware of what they were thinking
and you weren't living in a bubble so so
that's what I think is the biggest
opportunity right now with with what
we're seeing in this new social culture
emerging
you